Imagine, if you will, a time not
so long ago with the very
concept of intelligence felt
like something out of a spy
novel.
Secrets were guarded whispers,
you know, encased in lead line
vaults.
Grainy satellite images, almost
indistinguishable to the
untrained eye, were the
exclusive domain of a privileged
few, carefully analyzed behind
layers of security clearance.
Information truly was a rare
commodity, hoarded and
weaponized, used to shape the
fates of entire nations and
shift the global balance of
power.
That was the world we lived in.
But then, almost overnight,
everything changed.
The digital revolution wasn't
just about faster communication
or more convenient shopping.
It fundamentally altered our
relationship with information
itself.
Suddenly, every smartphone
camera became a potential lens
on the world, every network was
thrown wide open, and live feeds
began pouring out from, well,
everywhere.
What used to be the closely
guarded realm of intelligence
agencies and covert operatives
is now, astonishingly, available
to anyone with a Wi-Fi
connection and a curious mind.
OK, let's unpack this.
Today we're diving into a truly
fascinating and perhaps a little
unsettling transformation of how
we consume and interact with
information.
We're talking specifically about
open source intelligence, or
Ozent.
For years, Osun promised to be
this powerful force for
transparency, right?
A revolution in how we
understand the world,
democratizing access to truth.
But our sources suggest it's
morphed into something else
entirely, something far more
visceral and pervasive.
Open source entertainment OSINT.
What's truly compelling here is
how the very tools and
methodologies you know, the ones
designed to reveal objective
truth, are now not just
informing us, but profoundly
shaping our perception of
reality.
It's moving beyond pure
knowledge to provoke powerful
emotional responses.
We're going to explore this
profound shift today, dissect
its underlying drivers, and
really dig into the often
unforeseen implications outlined
in the material you've provided.
It compels us to ask, how does
this transformation
fundamentally change our
relationship with information
and ultimately, maybe with the
truth itself?
Our deep dive today is primarily
based on compelling excerpts
from a piece titled Osintis
Osin, When Open Source
Intelligence Stops Being About
Truth and Becomes the World's
Favorite Show by Chris Abraham.
It offers a provocative yet
incredibly insightful look at
how information is morphed into
spectacle and how we, the global
audience, have become not just
spectators, but active
participants in this new, never
ending show.
So let's start at the beginning.
What Olson was initially
conceived to be.
Historically, as we touched on,
intelligence was synonymous with
secrecy.
It was a world of hushed tones,
encrypted dossiers locked away
in secure facilities, and those
almost abstract satellite images
that required highly specialized
interpretation.
This is information strictly for
the privileged few governments,
military strategists, top secure
diplomats, and it was wielded
with immense power, directly
influencing geopolitical
decisions and dictating the
course of history.
It was a deliberately opaque
world by design.
But then came the digital
explosion.
As our source Chris Abraham so
aptly puts it, the world
changed.
The proliferation of digital
cameras from public CCTV to
private smartphones created an
unprecedented visual record of,
well, everything.
Networks that were once
proprietary or closed became
interconnected and increasingly
open.
Live feeds, once a niche
technology, started pouring out
from every corner of the globe,
capturing events as they
unfolded.
That highly guarded information,
once the exclusive domain of
intelligence agencies and high
level operatives, is now quite
literally available to anyone
with a Wi-Fi connection.
The original promise of Osent
Open Source Intelligence was
genuinely revolutionary in its
intent.
It was built in a very simple,
yet profoundly powerful idea.
If data is truly everywhere,
then theoretically anyone, not
just a state actor, can find and
assemble the truth.
This envisioned A radical new
era of transparency, A veritable
democratization of information.
The core belief was that the
collective power of Open Access,
coupled with collaborative
analysis could shed light on
events that were once
deliberately shrouded in
secrecy.
It was meant to be a tool for
empowerment, enabling a deeper
and more widespread
understanding of complex global
issues.
The very notion was that if
enough people could access,
scrutinize and cross reference
information from publicly
available sources, well,
obfuscation, propaganda and
deception would become far more
difficult to sustain.
And this revolution wasn't just
a theoretical pipe dream.
Its applications became
incredibly broad, spanning
numerous sectors and surprising
new actors.
Governments, of course, utilize
OSIN for strategic insights,
tracking everything from
economic trends to military
buildups.
Businesses leverage it for
competitive analysis, you know,
understanding market shifts and
competitor activities.
Journalists rely heavily on IT
for investigative reporting.
Breaking that would have been
impossible to verify just a few
decades ago, but the truly
disruptive element is how it
extends far beyond these
traditional users.
Even highly motivated hobbyists
and passionate armchair
detectives are now actively
engaging with Osen, often with
astonishing results.
The source highlights a
particularly striking and
illustrative example.
Random teenagers on Discord can
now outpace military analysts
and tracking troop movements.
And this isn't an exaggeration,
nor is it about specialized top
secret equipment.
It speaks to the sheer volume
and accessibility of Open Data
Sync, commercially available
satellite imagery that updates
daily, global flight tracking
apps that pinpoint aircraft in
real time, public social media
posts with geotags, open
government records, or even
seemingly innocuous metadata
embedded in photos and video
shared online.
These individuals, often
collaborating in distributed
networks, leverage readily
available online tools for
geolocation, image analysis, and
pattern recognition, effectively
pooling their analytical power
in a way that traditional
hierarchical intelligence
agencies often struggle to
replicate.
You know, due to their inherent
structural limitations and need
for secrecy.
The initial objective truly was
to provide objective knowledge
to enable a more profound and
fact based understanding of the
world around us.
Osund was about hard facts,
about verifiable information,
about meticulously putting
together pieces of a complex
puzzle to reveal a clearer, more
accurate picture of reality.
It was designed to inform, to
encourage critical thought and
to empower individuals to make
better informed decisions based
on demonstrable evidence.
This compels us to ask, if OSINT
was so effective at revealing
truth, at providing this
incredible new level of
transparency and empowering so
many, why would it then
transform into something else
entirely?
Why wasn't that foundational
pursuit of truth enough to
satisfy the audience?
This is precisely where the
narrative provided by our source
takes such a fascinating and
frankly disquieting turn.
That's a critical point.
If OSINT was designed to be this
powerful tool for truth and
transparency, why did it fall
short?
Why wasn't that enough to truly
satisfy the audience, leading to
this transformation you're
describing?
That's precisely the rub, as our
source Chris Abraham so
eloquently puts it.
He states directly, the truth
wasn't enough.
The truth never is.
People didn't just want to know,
they wanted to feel.
This is the core argument, the
fundamental shift that we're
exploring today.
In a world saturated with
information, raw emotional
content, especially spectacle,
is processed much faster and
resonates more deeply than
complex data.
It bypasses the analytical brain
going straight for the gut,
providing an instant
gratification that pure
knowledge, and it's often dry
and nuanced form simply cannot
consistently deliver.
This is where Osent Open Source
Entertainment truly enters the
picture.
It's the point where the pursuit
of factual understanding and
thoughtful analysis takes a
backseat to the pursuit of an
emotional connection of visceral
feeling and immediate reaction.
So the source isn't suggesting
this transformation was
accidental.
Rather, it portrays it as an
almost inevitable evolution
driven by fundamental aspects of
human psychology and the very
architecture or digital
platforms.
When you have access to such
wrong, unedited footage and
information, it often bypasses
the analytical, slower thinking
part of our brain and directly
triggers our limbic system, the
part responsible for emotion and
immediate reaction.
The impact of a dramatic visual,
especially 1, unfolding in real
time, is immediate and powerful.
The shift implies that the sheer
volume of data, paradoxically,
rather than making us more
discerning, has made us more
susceptible to the sensational.
It's like the world's largest,
most unedited, and endlessly
streaming reality show, and
we're all tuning in, driven by a
deep seated human craving for
narrative and emotional
resonance, even if that
narrative is raw and then
contextualized.
Exactly.
And the source elaborates on the
powerful, almost irresistible
drivers behind the shift to
oscend.
It states because watching is
addictive, consuming is easier
than thinking, and spectacle,
especially raw, uncut spectacle,
sells better than any report.
Think about that for a moment.
In an age of information
overload, where our cognitive
bandwidth is constantly
strained, the path of least
resistance often prevails.
It's undeniably more effortless,
and often more immediately
gratifying to passively scroll
through a dramatic compilation
of events or a shocking, easily
digestible clip than it is to
carefully analyze a detailed
report, cross reference multiple
data points, or engage in
sustained critical thinking.
The emotional high of a
compelling spectacle provides an
instant dopamine hit, a micro
reward that pure, often abstract
knowledge struggles to compete
with in the attention economy.
This distinction is absolutely
crucial for understanding the
profound implications of this
transformation.
The fundamental difference
between OSINT and OSINT, as our
source clearly defines it, is
that OSINT is supposed to make
you think.
OSINT just makes you watch.
OSINT demands active engagement,
rigorous critical analysis, the
synthesis of disparate pieces of
information, and the
intellectual effort to form a
coherent, nuanced understanding.
OSCENT, on the other hand, is
designed for passive, often
compulsive consumption.
It's about the immediate visual
impact, the emotional punch, the
visceral reaction.
Zooming out, the broader
implication here is that this
isn't just about how we
passively consume media.
It represents A fundamental and
profound shift in our very
relationship with information
itself.
It suggests that our primary
mode of engagement has
transitioned from one of
critical inquiry and active
sense making to 1 of largely
uncritical observation, driven
primarily by the pursuit of
instant sensation and emotional
arousal.
Now where do we see this
phenomenon play out most
dramatically, perhaps even
disturbingly, in the real world?
Our source points directly to
modern conflict, arguing that
war itself is transforming into
global, live content.
The peace zeroes in on the
ongoing conflict in Ukraine,
describing it not as the
traditional military engagement,
but strikingly, as the video
game war.
The immediacy and the sheer
volume of raw, unfiltered
footage streaming out of this
conflict are genuinely unlike
anything we've witnessed before.
War in Ukraine isn't delayed,
it's practically unfolding in
real time.
We're talking about unverified
drone footage of armored columns
getting obliterated streaming on
Telegram channels just hours
after the strikes, and those
same channels are actively
posting trench firefights like
sports highlights, complete with
dramatic music and quick cuts.
Think about that for a moment.
Real military engagements.
Real people in real danger,
being presented in a format that
mirrors highlight reels from a
sporting event or even a first
person shooter game.
There's a stark contrast
presented here between
consumption and analysis, and it
speaks directly to the Ozent
phenomenon.
Our source points out that you
can watch a tank explode, replay
it, meme it, cut it to EDM.
This isn't an intelligence
analyst pouring over strategic
implications or troop movements.
This is a casual viewer engaging
with the footage's pure,
unadulterated entertainment.
While analysts pick apart
missile trajectories on Twitter,
meticulously examining every
detail for actionable
intelligence, millions of casual
viewers just watch for the boom.
The focus shifts entirely from
understanding the how and why to
simply witnessing the most
dramatic, visually impactful
effect.
The source powerfully reiterates
this idea, claiming that this
isn't classified Intel, it's
content.
The line between real world
conflict and digital
entertainment has become
profoundly blurred.
It's no longer primarily about
military secrets or strategic
advantage.
It's about what goes viral, what
garners the most views and
shares.
Exactly.
And what's truly striking here
is the source suggests that
Ukraine isn't an isolated case
or an anomaly, but rather it's
quickly becoming the blueprint
for future conflicts.
The peace asserts it's the model
every war now runs parallel to
its own live broadcast.
This transforms conflict from a
distant, abstract concept often
filtered through traditional
news channels, into an
immediate, ongoing, and quite
literally binge worthy event for
a global audience.
Within this new model, the
gamification of war becomes
incredibly apparent.
Consider how Twitter accounts
are posting updated maps like
scoreboard graphics,
transforming the complex, fluid
ebb and flow of battle into
something resembling a live
sports sticker, complete with
clear teams and scores.
And Telegram channels,
meanwhile, are sharing first
person drone kills, literally
putting the viewer directly into
the perspective of the weapon,
chillingly blurring the line
between actual combat and a
video game simulation.
Independent analysts, often
operating with anonymous
avatars, become minor
celebrities within their niche
communities, their detailed
threads dissecting every battle
and tactical maneuver, like
sports commentators breaking
down a major game.
It's even worth noting that
traditional Western intelligence
agencies are quietly using these
same open data streams,
sometimes even engaging with the
crowd, highlighting just how
pervasive and influential this
public information sphere has
become.
The sheer entertainment value,
as the source notes, is
undeniable.
Drone videos track individual
soldiers like ants on a
battlefield, and convoys explode
in cinematic fireballs.
We of the global audience find
ourselves cheering or jeering
depending on our pre-existing
allegiances, like they're
watching a playoff series.
This is a profound departure
from the slow, highly filtered
CNN coverage of Desert Storm
from decades past.
This is a TikTok war.
It's bite sized, addictive, made
to loop.
This fundamental shift from
thoughtful, contextualized
consumption to immediate,
repeatable, and often
decontextualized engagement is
incredibly significant.
The algorithms, the very
backbone of these social media
platforms, have actively twisted
it.
They are explicitly designed to
boost the most shocking clips,
the bloodiest explosions, the
most dramatic moments, because
these are the elements that
generate maximum engagement,
shares and watch time.
And in this relentless pursuit
of virality and attention,
context dies in the feed.
What's left is an intelligent
it's spectacle, No, this compels
us to consider what this means
for our collective understanding
of conflict.
Are we truly informed by
watching these constant streams
of clips?
Or are we merely entertained,
perhaps even desensitized by the
sheer spectacle, losing our
capacity for empathy or nuanced
understanding in the process?
And if Ukraine serves as this
chilling model for how conflict
is evolving, then Gaza,
according to our source, is
described as the purest example
of Osant collapsing into Osant.
This particular conflict truly
underscores the ubiquitous and
inescapable nature of access to
raw war footage.
You don't need to be a
government operative.
You don't need a top secret
security clearance to know
what's happening on the ground.
You simply open your phone.
TikTok is absolutely saturated
with immediate, raw footage of
bombed out streets.
Instagram has endless reels of
trying mothers, often shared
with highly emotional captions
designed to elicit a specific
reaction.
And ex, formerly Twitter,
presents a steady drip of drone
footage, some real, some fake,
all shared like clips from a
dystopian reality show.
This isn't curated news designed
for balanced reporting.
It's an unfiltered, overwhelming
torrent of images and videos,
frequently devoid of context,
verification or journalistic
standards.
What's absolutely crucial to
grasp here is that this isn't
just passive observation of
events, it's become a deeply
performative space.
Both sides involved in the
conflict understand implicitly
that the cameras are always
rolling and that their actions,
as well as the visual
representation of those actions,
are being consumed and judged
globally. 204 Seven.
Our source highlights how this
awareness fundamentally
influences their output.
Israel shapes its footage for
Western audiences.
Precision order.
We targeted militants.
Their aim, quite clearly, is to
portray a controlled, legitimate
military operation adhering to
establish norms of engagement.
Conversely, Hamas shapes its
footage for the global S chaos,
destruction.
Look what they're doing to us.
Their aim is to elicit maximum
sympathy and outrage,
highlighting the devastating
human cost and the perceived
injustice, appealing to a
different set of cultural and
political sensibilities.
Each side is acutely aware of
its global audience and tailors
its visual messaging
accordingly.
And this performative aspect
extends far beyond the direct
combatants, drawing in a broader
cast of characters.
NGO's, aid workers, journalists,
each becomes, in a sense, a
character in this complex,
unfolding drama.
Their posts, their live streams,
and their raw footage, while
often intended to advocate for
humanitarian causes or inform
the public, ultimately become
part of the broader ongoing
spectacle.
Their very presence and the
content they produce add layers
to the narrative, amplifying
certain perspectives and
emotional dimensions.
The suffering, the source
powerfully reminds us, is
absolutely real and horrifying
for those caught in the
conflict.
But equally real is the framing,
the deliberate way in which this
reality is presented, packaged
and consumed by the global
audience.
So how do we, the global
audience, interact with this
constant stream?
Our source says with a stark
bluntness.
We eat it up.
We scroll, we react, we share.
We watch war not to understand
it, but to feel it.
This, fundamentally, is the
essence of OSIM.
Gaza isn't just a humanitarian
tragedy or a complex
geopolitical conflict.
It's described as a feed.
It's season after season of
atrocity.
Clips cut to evoke maximum
outrage or sympathy, depending
on who's doing the editing.
This framing, this packaging of
profound human suffering into
digestible, emotionally charged
clips, transforms A devastating
reality into a continuous, often
harrowing drama.
It compels us to ask.
While the suffering is
undeniably real for those
trapped within the conflict
zones, for the rest of us
consuming this torrent of
images, we watch it like
content.
It becomes a form of
entertainment, albeit A
disturbing one, rather than a
catalyst for deep analytical
understanding or meaningful
sustained action.
The sheer volume and relentless
speed of the speed can also lead
to a kind of emotional fatigue
or desensitization, where the
gravity of the events diminishes
with each successive fleeting
image, turning tragedy into
fleeting spectacle.
But this phenomenon of ascent is
transformation of information
into spectacle isn't confined to
grand geopolitical conflicts or
war zones.
You see the exact same thing
playing out, often in equally
disturbing ways with local
policing.
With the source refers to his
cop porn and crash cams.
The ubiquity of footage in
everyday life is truly
astonishing Now cop pullover
videos, high speed dash Cam
chases, body Cam arrests.
They're everywhere you look
online, easily accessible on
platforms like YouTube, TikTok
and Reddit.
Entire YouTube empires have been
built and thrive on cutting
publicly available police
footage into adrenaline fueled
dramatic reels.
Think about the narrative arc.
A suspect flees.
The sirens wail dramatically.
Spike strips are deployed in
slow motion.
The chase culminates in a
dramatic crash or a foot
pursuit.
It's instant content designed
for maximum engagement.
Millions of people watch these
clips compulsively.
It's OSIN because the footage is
often made public by law or
through public record requests.
But it's fundamentally OSIN
because it's consumed like
popcorn for pure entertainment
value, often with a very little
deeper thought given to the
complex implications, the legal
ramifications, or the human
impact in context of the
situations unfolding.
This isn't entirely new, of
course.
The long running reality TV show
Cops was in many ways the
original Osen turned Osen.
Police departments provided the
raw footage, and producers then
expertly crafted it into
dramatic arcs with compelling
storylines which audiences
eagerly consumed for decades.
But now, instead of a single
curated show, there's an
infinite, unedited feed
accessible to an E47.
Police departments themselves
often release body Cam clips as
part of their public relations
strategy, aiming to control the
narrative content creators and
scrape these public records for
dash Cam footage and other
incident videos.
And the audience?
They get their fix in an
infinite scroll.
Always something new, always
something more dramatic to
watch.
A particularly fascinating
insight the source provides
highlights how Russians in fact
pioneered the widespread use of
dash Cam videos, noting that it
seemed like every car with a
dash Cam meant every accident
online.
This cultural phenomenon led to
a truly compulsive viewing
habit, one that quickly spread
globally.
People would watch everything
from minor Fender benders to
intense displays of road rage
and even serious, horrifying
Hwy. carnage.
The types of content were
incredibly varied, spanning the
gamut of human mishap and
aggression on the roads, yet the
consumption was remarkably
consistent and insatiable.
This phenomenon is largely
explained as an appeal to
instant dopamine, a quick hit to
our brains reward system.
The source gives vivid examples
like four way stop fails, semi
trucks tipping, a Mustang
spinning out.
It's instant dopamine.
These clips, much like the
explosion videos from war zones,
don't necessarily require
extensive explanation, deep
contextualization or complex
analysis to be immediately
impactful.
They just need to play.
The raw visual impact is
immediate and often shocking,
triggering a quick fleeting
burst of engagement and novelty.
Think about how often you've
caught yourself scrolling past
similar clips on your own social
media feeds almost against your
will.
It powerfully, highly highlights
how readily we consume raw,
often uncontextualized
spectacle, even when it involves
real world danger, distress, or
serious injury, simply for that
quick hit of novelty, surprise,
or even a perverse fascination
with chaos and mishap.
It taps into a very primal human
curiosity about things going
wrong.
If Ascent as a raw, unfiltered
stream of information has a
cultural homeland, the source
makes a compelling argument that
it's Worldstarhiphop.
Before the term viral even
became mainstream and
universally understood,
Worldstar transformed raw street
fights, intense confrontations,
and pure urban chaos into
content that spread like
wildfire across the Internet.
It was essentially the
unfiltered, often unedited feed
of everyday human conflict,
shared for maximum spectacle and
shock value.
This platform was absolutely
instrumental in demonstrating A
profound shift how everyday
violence could be made
shareable, how public
humiliation could become
content, and, critically, how
millions of people would
actively TuneIn, often
compulsively, to witness it.
It normalized the idea that raw,
uncontextualized conflict and
confrontation, even profound
human distress, could be a
primary source of mass
entertainment.
And taking that ethos, that raw,
immediate, often unedited view
of life and packaging it for
mass consumption is precisely
where the Ring camera comes into
play.
Bringing this phenomenon
directly into the hardest
suburbia, the source points out
how every porch is a
surveillance post, every
doorbell a lens.
What was originally designed and
marketed primarily as a home
security device has rapidly,
almost inevitably, evolved into
a pervasive new form of
entertainment content.
Footage of package thefts,
quirky pranksters, unexpected
encounters with strange animals,
even mundane arguments or
disputes between neighbors.
Ring footage now floods the
Internet, often shared
gleefully.
It's no longer just about
protecting your home from
intruders.
It's increasingly about
providing endlessly amusing or
sometimes alarming content.
Totally.
If we connect this to the bigger
picture, the Ring camera and the
vast ecosystem of doorbell
cameras like it has really taken
that raw, unfiltered Worldstar
ethos and profoundly
democratized it, bringing it
right into our quiet suburban
overhoods.
It's moved well beyond just
being a security measure.
It's now a widespread, almost
constant source of casual
entertainment, a kind of
neighborhood watch turned
reality TV channels across
various platforms.
Post endless compilations of
this footage, you see clips of
porch pirates tackled in comedic
fashion, Amazon drivers throwing
boxes with reckless abandoned,
or Karen screaming at HOA.
As in Absurd displays of
entitlement, The source
effectively describes how the
suburban mundane becomes binge
worthy.
What was once private, or at
least unrecorded and unseen by
the masses, is now routinely
captured, shared globally, and
consumed for amusement, gossip,
or simple curiosity.
This powerfully suggests that
the desire for spectacle, for
raw, unmediated drama, isn't
confined to grand dramatic
events like wars or high speed
chases.
It has fully infiltrated the
most ordinary, trivial and even
private aspects of our daily
lives, transforming our routine
interactions into a constant
stream of potential highly
consumable content.
It represents A fundamental
shift in what we collectively
consider engaging or
entertaining.
So what does this pervasive
shift mean for us, the audience?
What truly makes OSCENT
different from old fashioned
voyeurism, the kind we've always
been drawn to as humans, is the
element of participation.
The audience isn't passive
anymore.
We don't just watch, we analyze,
we speculate.
We actively contribute to the
unfolding narrative, or what
often appears to be.
The narrative, even if it's
incomplete or misleading, is
transformed into a dynamic,
interactive experience far
removed from simply tuning into
a curated news broadcast or
watching a pre produced
documentary.
And this participatory element
has led to a fascinating and
often problematic rise in
crowdsourced investigations.
For instance, after a major
event like a bombing or a
natural disaster, you routinely
see online communities on
platforms like Reddit able to
geolocate the exact site within
minutes simply by meticulously
analyzing public footage, open
source maps, and geographical
landmarks.
After a high profile crime,
countless TikTok sleuths jump
into action attempting to
identify suspects by
scrutinizing grainy surveillance
footage or social media
profiles.
While this can, in some rare
instances lead to correct
identifications or genuinely
valuable leads, the source
astutely points out that it's
often disastrously wrong.
This highlights the dual and
highly problematic nature of
ocean.
When it morphs into ocean, the
very same tools, the very same
open platforms that can expose
truth and hold power
accountable, can also be misused
to spread misinformation, jump
to baseless conclusions, and
even unjustly target innocent
individuals with devastating
consequences.
OSINT empowers the crowd with
unprecedented access to
information, but OSENT, by
turning this into a high stakes
spectator sport, has the
potential to transform that
empowered crowd into an
uncontrolled, often reckless and
sometimes dangerous mob.
And this crowd sourced
investigation, this collective
digital detective work, has
become incredibly addictive.
The source explicitly describes
it as the gamification of
investigation.
Think of what makes a video game
or a competitive challenge so
utterly compelling.
Clear objectives, immediate
feedback on your actions, and
the inherent thrill of a win or
discovery.
Here, people don't just
passively watch anymore, they
actively play detective.
They work diligently to solve
digital puzzles, chase down
digital leads, and eagerly post
their findings for others to
validate or critique, often
vying for recognition or the
prestige of being the first to
break a crucial detail.
Every click they make is a move
in this intricate unfolding
game.
Every share they distribute is a
point scored, a micro reward
that fuels the next step and
reinforces the behavior,
creating a powerful
psychological loop.
You get that potent hit of
dopamine when you feel like
you've contributed to solving
something, even if it's just a
small, often fragmented piece of
a much larger and frequently
chaotic.
Puzzle.
But there's a profound and often
devastating downside to this
gamified approach.
As the source acutely observes,
the game has no referee, and
innocent people sometimes lose.
Without proper oversight,
without adherence to
journalistic ethics, or without
the crucial guardrails of legal
frameworks and due process, the
crowd sourced investigative
process can very quickly devolve
into vigilantism, rampant
gossip, and the rapid spread of
unverified claims that destroy
reputations and lives.
The immediate gratification of
solving a puzzle or identifying
A suspect can completely
override the crucial need for
rigorous verification, factual
accuracy, and respect for
individual rights.
This compels us to ask in the
relentless pursuit of the game,
in the thrill of the chase and
the satisfying feeling of
uncovering something, are we
collectively losing sight of our
ethical responsibilities or the
true and potentially devastating
impact that our online actions
can have on real individuals
caught in the crosshairs of this
digital spectacle?
The pursuit of the win or the
ephemeral satisfaction of being
right can tragically eclipse the
pursuit of justice or accuracy.
And all of this, every single
click, every single view, every
single share feeds the hungry
algorithms that power our
digital world.
This brings us directly to the
ocean economy, where as our
source highlights virality,
often brutally, Trump's truth.
While OSINT might be incredibly
valuable for governments, for
militaries, and for corporations
seeking strategic advantages and
deep insights, OSINT Open Source
Entertainment is explicitly
designed to print money for
creators and most importantly,
for the platforms themselves.
The economic incentive is clear,
powerful, and relentless.
Our source provides specific,
compelling examples of this
monetization in action.
YouTube, for instance, monetizes
police chases, turning real
world law enforcement incidents
into lucrative ad revenue
generators.
Tech talk aggressively pushes
ring Cam clips, transforming
mundane suburban surveillance
into a constant source of
entertainment and engagement.
The Telegram channels, often
focusing on conflict footage,
collect significant donations
from their followers, who are
captivated by drone strikes and
military engagements and X
accounts.
The new Twitter expertly farm
engagement for sharing the
latest, most dramatic drone
strikes, which can then be
monetized through advertising or
other revenue models.
The underlying principle is
powerfully simple.
Information in its raw, factual
and often dry form may be a
valuable commodity, but
entertainment, especially
dramatic, raw and emotionally
charged entertainment, is an
absolute gold line in the
attention economy.
Right.
And what's truly fascinating
here is how like any commodity
in a market driven system, OSEN
actively bends and warps reality
to fit its economic imperatives.
The focus fundamentally shifts
from objective representation to
maximizing engagement metrics.
The source details, the precise
techniques employed.
Footage is edited for impact.
This means that clips are often
selectively cut to highlight
only the most shocking, the most
dramatic, or the most
emotionally charged moments,
even if this drastically
distorts the broader context or
the full narrative of what
transpired.
Simultaneously, context is
stripped away, leaving only the
raw, visceral image or moment to
stand alone.
The crucial nuances, the
essential background
information, the broader
implications, These are
systematically sacrificed
because they don't immediately
contribute to virality, shares
or sustained engagement.
In this burgeoning ocean
economy.
Truth is secondary to virality.
The accuracy or the factual
completeness of the information
becomes significantly less
important than its inherent
ability to spread rapidly, to
generate strong reactions, and
to keep eyes glued to screens
for as long as possible.
If we connect this to the bigger
picture, the implications are
vast and concerning.
This isn't just about what we as
individual users choose to
watch.
It's about how the platforms
themselves are inherently
incentivized to present
information.
Their core business models,
driven by advertising revenue
and engagement metrics, are
designed to prioritize
sensationalism over substance
and entertainment value over
factual accuracy.
This fundamentally alters the
entire information landscape,
creating a system where what is
entertaining, shocking, or
emotionally resonant is often
rewarded over what is truly
important, accurate, or
intellectually enriching.
So to bring it all together, and
here's what truly struck me when
reading this source from Chris
Abraham, the transformation is
complete.
Open source intelligence ascent
no longer serves just to inform
us.
Its primary undeniable function
has become to entertain us.
The original promise of
transparency, of leveraging
readily available data to
understand the world more deeply
and objectively, has been
largely overshadowed by an
incredibly powerful, almost
irresistible pole towards pure
spectacle and raw emotion.
Exactly.
The source powerfully reiterates
this core unsettling message.
The CCTV clip, the drone strike,
the Ring camera prank, they are
all part of the same spectacle.
The world has, in an
unprecedented way, become
entirely open sourced and the
curtain is always up.
There's no off switch, no moment
when the camera cease to roll or
the feed stop flowing.
Ascent in its original form has
not just evolved, but
fundamentally transformed into
Ascent, and the show quite
simply never ends.
This compels us to ask a
critical question for all of us
immersed in this digital age.
How does this constant, never
ending stream of raw, often
uncontextualized, and frequently
sensational content impact our
capacity for empathy?
And equally important, how does
it affect our ability to engage
in critical thought, to discern
objective fact from carefully
crafted performance, or to truly
understand the complex, nuanced
reality is behind the
compelling, ever present
spectacle?
So what does this all mean for
you as you navigate your daily
information landscape?
As our sources powerfully
suggest, OSINT was supposed to
reveal truth.
OSINT reveals feeling.
The line between the two, if it
ever truly existed, is now
incredibly blurred, if not
entirely gone.
Wars are fought not only on the
physical ground, but
simultaneously on the digital
feed, consumed and reacted to by
millions globally in real time.
Crimes are no longer just solved
in forensic labs or deliberated
in courtrooms.
They're debated, speculated
upon, and solved in common
threads and on viral social
media posts.
Every camera you encounter,
whether it's on a street corner,
a drone overhead, or a doorbell
on a neighbor's porch, is a
potential lens for this never
ending, all-encompassing show.
So consider deeply as you scroll
through your feed today and
every day, whether you're
genuinely seeking understanding
or if you're just watching the
show.